[Music]
Christmas The Most Wonderful Time of the
Year with the most festive movies of the
year but not all Christmas movies are
created equally on one side you have the
theatrical studio Christmas movie we're
talking your eles we're talking your
home alone you're the Santa Clauses
these films aren't Blockbusters per se
their budgets are often medium to small
but they're significant when compared to
the micro-budget Christmas movies that
our moms have grown to love like time
for him to come home for Christmas or
time for me to come home for Christmas
or time for you to come home for
Christmas or time for us to come home
for Christmas or a cookie cutter
Christmas okay that last one was a
departure I know but I lumped it in
because I actually spoke to the guy who
made the music for it hey I'm Russ
Howard and I am a film composer almost
every day on Hallmark during Christmas
season there's a good chance if you turn
on the TV then you you'll run into some
of my music I called him up to talk
about how all the Christmas movies we
know and love and the ones we might not
know yet sound
Christmasy like many things those
decisions start with money while Studio
film budgets are in this range Hallmark
movies are generally made for $2 million
and under although I think most of them
are shot for maybe like 4 to
500,000 and and less when it comes to
music only a small percentage of the all
budget is allocated for it traditionally
it's about 3 to 5% 3% being more the
average and then if it's a very s heavy
movie that would push it up to that
5% let's take elf as an example it cost
roughly $33 million to make 5% of that
is just over 1.6 million more than the
whole budget of some Hallmark films so
they were able to afford a scene like
this where Zoe dianel and will Ferell
sing a popular song
can't which uh I can't actually play
more than that here for fear of getting
flagged for copyright infringement but
anyways songs like that one cost a
pretty penny and just how much is a
pretty penny well I emailed a bunch of
music supervisors to try and find out
and one got back to me Lexi Brewer she
mostly works on the cable TV side of
things and via email she told me that
the traditional Christmas songs we know
and love tend to cost somewhere in the
ballpark of
$25,000 per side per side is important
to note here because when you want to
license a song for a movie there's
actually two sides to every clearance
like let's say you want us to play
Christmas baby please come home in your
movie I don't know if I know that one
exactly you definitely do someone that's
like Christmas the snow's coming down oh
yes of course um editor notes to uh
Michael blueblade darling love and
anyone else who sings this song Please
Don't sue us for doing that the first Fe
you have have to pay is for the
composition of the song using those
notes in that order $25,000 or
thereabouts goes to the music publisher
the second feed depends on what those
notes in that order sound like you could
have the original
recording or the cover by Michael
blé either way you need to square up for
at least another 25k but depending on
the song The Artist might want more and
then the overall cost increases Lexi
explain with this example of Mariah
Carey if she wanted twice as much as the
traditional rate on her side then the
other side would likely match doubling
the total feet of course these are all
loose numbers these kinds of deals
generally aren't made public and Lexi
works on the TV side of things she
didn't know the numbers specifically but
she said that streaming and Theatrical
fees are likely more expensive so that
might not be exactly what Mariah or
other artists might charge which is why
you would hear other artists covering
Beetles songs a lot of
times because they could pay for the
right to use the song but not for the
right to use the Beatles not less thany
music ahead of time can get you into
some sticky situations like Russ was
telling me about this one time where a
rough cut for a film that he was working
on for Hallmark had a scene where
character sang Rudolph the Red-nose
Reindeer you know I get to be the bucket
of cold ice water on their Christmas
dreams and say hey guys like these songs
very well could cost more than the movie
budget you know to license they ended up
cutting that scene from the film but if
they would have known what songs do and
don't have copyright there's a way that
they could have made a similar scene for
free a lot of the Christmas songs we
love are not what we call public domain
public domain or in other words free
from copyright it's the reason that you
hear this song in so many
movies
you know this going be a lot easier if
we were facing the way EAS facing the
other
[Music]
way what have you done when it comes to
public domain in the US every piece of
creative work made before 1928 is
totally open for anyone to use anything
created after that for the most part is
AOK 70 years after the creator dies so
this song you're hearing right now it
was written by chaikovsky for the n
cracker in
1892 public domain what's great about
the public domain Christmas songs is
it's this like shared cultural
experience that we all have these cost
nothing and are Christmas as heck
they're used in movies big I'm sorry I'm
late I was what the what is that and
small white and because they're open to
the public composers like us can
recompose bits and pieces with no
worries about having to pay a huge fee
or even worse getting sued the trick is
recomposing them to fit the mood of a
particular scene if I was going to take
like Joy to the
World and then I wanted to make it maybe
a little more Moody I would
[Music]
maybe my job is like how do I take that
and make it work to a scene this is Deck
the Halls fit for a baking
[Music]
Montage but for me the most interesting
rearrangements of these classic songs
are the more warped ones Russell's able
to make Sinister versions of songs we
know and love for the Christmas slasher
It's a Wonderful
[Music]
[Applause]
knife Joy to the World in like kind of
like an evil version did you dtune the
bells too yes yeah they're they're a
little bit D- tuned so they sound a
little bit
off there are many ways to we arrange
the classic songs we all know and love
but sometimes the cheat code to the
Christmas sound can boil down to a
simple instrument tinkling
bells and then of
course but it seems like no matter how
you get there the most effective way to
spread Christmas cheer is public domain
Christmas songs for all to
hear as we wrap up this festive episode
we here at Vox have a request since 2020
box has turn to readers to help keep our
journalism free we believe that
information like this doesn't belong
behind a pay wall and if you believe
that too then help support our mission
by going to box.com give- now to make a
contribution the goal is 95,000 gifts by
the end of the year and that's just a
few days away so click the link in the
description to learn
more